welcome back to New rockstars I'm Eric
Boss and this is a breakdown of the
trailer for Madame web the Sony
spiderverse movie coming February 2024
we think this movie starring toota
Johnson as Cassandra Cassie Webb a
paramedic in Manhattan with Clairvoyant
abilities based on the Marvel psychic
first voiced by Stan Le's wife Joan in
the Spider-Man animated series in the
90s and co-starring Sydney Sweeney as
Julia Carpenter Spiderwoman Celeste OK
Conor as mattye Franklin Spiderwoman
Isel mered as Ana Corazon AR Spider Girl
and tahar Raheem as an Ezekiel Sims
version of Spider-Man as well as Adam
Scott in some unknown role that might be
Uncle Ben let's break down this trailer
shot by shot connect this all to Venom
and Craven if we can and figure out
what's going on before Dakota Chon's
voice puts us to sleep all right let's
get
started hey come on get your stuff let's
[Music]
go okay Cassie stands in front of the
fourstar diner so the four-star Diner
was first referenced in The Amazing
Spider-Man number 30 in 2001 which was
the first appearance of the Ezekiel Sims
character this Diner in the comics is
really hang out for Peter and his
friends and in front of Steiner you can
also see a working pay phone her first
clue that this film is taking place in
the past because nowhere has these
anymore from outside the diner you can
actually see Julia and Maddie dancing on
the table goofing around with some boys
on the Midtown High basketball team you
can actually see their shirts inside and
of course Midtown high is a school Peter
Parker goes to so this is obviously a
different Universe than the MCU which
Marvel Studios kept designating as 616
and Spider-Man across the spiderverse
which was also produced by Sony the
Venom Universe was designated as Earth
688 but this movie's official
description begins with quote meanwhile
in Another Universe which was the way in
into the spiderverse the post credit
scene designated that we were
transferring to Miguel o harz universe
and using it here indicates that this
movie is taking place in a completely
different Universe from any other
spiderverse that we've seen before like
it's not the Sam Ry Toby McGuire
Spider-Man universe it's not the mark
Webb Andrew Garfield Spider-Man universe
it's not the Marvel Cinematic Universe
it's not the animated spiderverse and
it's probably not Venom's universe or
Craven's universe or morbius Universe it
kind of seems like these three girls are
wearing color-coded wardrobes that are
consistent with their superhero costumes
Maddie wears light blue with red stripes
Ana wears a yellow top Julia wears black
and white Anya's shirt actually reads I
eat math for breakfast which is the kind
of shirt Tom Holland Peter Parker would
really be into but then Ezekiel Sims
Spider-Man enters this Diner and he
looks pretty menacing there's quite a
bit of interesting detail in this
Spider-Man costume that I'll dig into
later but things may not be what they
seem with this guy Cassie smashes a
bottle on his head before we see him
toss her to the ground as this room
inverts from his point of view very
Spider-Man move actually at the very
beginning of the shot you can see Julia
on the ground there incapacitated so
presumably he took her out first or
maybe even killed her here Ezekiel
similarly chokes Maddie and then choke
slams Ana and then flips the KN out of
Cassie's hand to stab her leading to her
looping back to outside the diner to try
this again we are reminded of the
currying let's do this one more time by
all the Spider-Man I in the spiderverse
films all right let's do this one last
time let's do things differently this
time all right people let's do this one
last time so who is everyone and what
the hell is going on so Madam Webb or
Cassandra Webb first appeared in The
Amazing Spider-Man number 210 from 1980
where she originated from Salem Oregon
and was a disabled Clairvoyant and
precognitive mutant who worked as a
professional psychic web got her
nickname because of her medical
condition required her to be hooked up
to an elaborate chair with a series of
metallic tubes that resemble called a
spider web so she's not really anyone
who is bitten by a spider it's just that
she like many of Peter Parker's villains
in the pages of Spider-Man comics just
has some kind of interesting visual
parallel to spiders like Dak is a being
that has eight legs right but the
character would go on to have greater
significance to the lore of Spider-Man
she is considered to be associated with
the spiderverse and this Cosmic Force
someone deeply tied to the Web of Life
and Destiny she appeared in Spider-Man
the Animated Series in the '90s where
she was voiced by Stanley's wife Joan
Lee and in the Ultimate Spider-Man from
the 2010s we got another version of
Madam web this time juliia Carpenter
taking up the mantle and we should note
that in the animated across the
spiderverse film miles's guidance
counselor voiced by Rachel drach was
named C Weber which might have been a
reference to this character now Julia
Carpenter Spiderwoman first appeared in
1984 as part of a secret Wars miniseries
who got her powers from a mix of spider
venom and plant extracts in addition to
becoming Madame web at some point in her
future she appeared in a number of
crossover story lines and also cameoed
in animated form in the background of
across the spiderverse Maddie Franklin
Spiderwoman first appeared in 1998 and
became Spiderwoman in 1999 she's the of
J Jonah Jameson with memorable arcs in
the Jessica Jones Alias run and dead no
more the Clone conspiracy storyline with
Ben Riley then Ana Kon AKA Spider Girl
and later Arna might have had the most
badass looking cameo in across the
spiderverse she debuted in 2004 and is
probably best known as the main
character in the Spider-Man 2017
animated series on Disney XD meanwhile
Ezekiel Sims debuted in that Amazing
Spider-Man number 30 from 2001 as a
barefooted weirdo who encounters Peter
Parker with similar powers to Spider-Man
but he got his powers we learn later
from spider totems while exploring
jungle ruins he asks Peter Parker some
interesting questions about how exactly
he got his powers from that spider bite
which leads to us learning that it
wasn't the radioactivity from the spider
bite that gave Peter Parker his powers
but rather part of a cosmic event that
links all spider People Into the Web of
Life and Destiny and that Peter Parker
was really selected by a figure called
the Great Weaver Ezekiel is really
trying to stop Morlin and the inheritors
beings who hunt spider people throughout
the Multiverse and bead on spider things
so here Cassandra or Cassie has a
clairvoyant to can see the future plays
through these Visions in her mind kind
of like Doctor Strange foreseeing future
events in Infinity War but in this case
she's not actually time traveling or
time slipping she's really just kind of
like mentally playing them out in an
additional vignette that also released
today the film's director SJ Clarkson
said that even though Cassie Webb has
visions of the Future these Visions are
quite fragmented because she doesn't see
anything clearly or it could be that
maybe cass's Visions are real in a
multiversal sense because there is a
chance this movie goes more into the
Multiverse than we think okay let's move
on a week ago I spent my life racing
Against Time time I'm going to help you
out today okay trying to save people who
are running out of it until one
moment changed
everything come on Welcome Back to the
land that we're living Cassie in this
movie is a New York paramedic in the
promotional vignette Dakota Johnson says
that this movie takes place before the
character ends up in the wheelchair so
by the end of this film we might see a
version of the character more like her
comic book and animated appearances we
see the New York trib Bridge though
principal photography of this filmm
happened in Boston there is a classic is
this car going to fall off the bridge or
not moment remember Spider-Man no way
home had Peter saving the dean of
admissions for MIT this way and in The
Amazing Spider-Man film in 2012 Andrew
Garfield Peter Parker has to save a kid
from the car hanging off the bridge when
he was fighting the lizard Adam Scott
plays another paramedic whose name is
unknown as of this taping but there are
rumors he is playing Ben Parker Uncle
Ben which would line up with this movie
being set in an ERA with payones but the
shot at Manhattan includes towers that
were not built in the city until the
past decade so I don't know Emma Roberts
is going to appear in this movie part
unknown it is rumored that she's playing
Mary Parker Uncle Ben's sister who is
Peter Parker's mom we get some crit dick
imagery here the windshield splinters
into a spiderweb pattern we see a woman
in water giving birth and on the left
side of screen some netted fabric that
kind of looks like the texture of the
Toby Maguire Spider-Man suit remember
where the webbing stuck out above the
red fabric this mother seems to die as
she leaves her baby nearby this Fabric
and her finger just kind of runs down
that little baby hand and it seems like
Cassie is witnessing all this from
behind a literal spiderweb in the memory
that she talks about later in this
trailer referring to her mom in Peru so
I think we are seeing her fractured
perception of the web of life and
Destiny while Cassandra Web is not
necessarily herself a spider thing at
least historically in the comics so I
think Cassie is witnessing the birth of
some other spider thing maybe one of
these spider women maybe the birth of
Ezekiel Sims maybe the birth of herself
maybe the birth of this universe's Peter
Parker which would make Adam Scott being
Uncle Ben maybe saying welcome back to
the land of living a bit ironic does his
mom give him birth in the shot look like
Emma Roberts to you it's kind of hard
for me to tell but let's move on I don't
understand what's happening I've been
having
Vision I knew he was going to
die I think I'm seeing the future okay
so Cassie tells the doctor about her
Visions about knowing someone was going
to die and seeing the future this doctor
seems to be using an older computer so
again this might be like in the early
2000s or the mid 2000s we see Cassie
performing CPR on a construction worker
who then morphs into a fellow paramedic
as cass's hands become bloody this
paramedic will later be hit by a truck
confirming that Cassie can see the
future and the way this manifests is a
vision of Cassie trying to save someone
just to end up with the blood on her
hands of the person faded to die so she
takes personal responsibility to try to
prevent those Fates we've all had the
experience of going to a friend's house
and seeing something on their shelf that
makes your jaw drop well with fanhome
you can be that friend fanhome is a
brand dedicated to developing unique
Collections and buildup models from
Brands like Star Wars Marvel and more a
fan home subscription gets you magazines
loaded with trivia and stories about
your favorite fan but also everything
you need to build your very own
Millennium Falcon phenom's Millennium
Falcon model is so detailed the
completed ship is over 30 in long and
the pieces are all diecast metal in ABS
plastic so it looks great plus the
cockpit and thrusters light up which is
super fun with fanhome subscription you
get new parts every month plus
instructions on how to put everything
together so you can build your model up
bit by bit rather than be overwhelmed
trying to do it all at once on top of
that you'll also get a Millennium Falcon
mug a hat and a binder a Phan home
subscription is perfect way to make your
collection stand out to get started just
click the link in the description below
and then on to the next clip New York
City is a whole new level of crazy these
days okay Cassie sits on a train that I
have never seen the interior of on any
New York City train line but much like
the movie final destination or really
the time looping on a train movie source
code or kind of like David Dunn's
ability to see people's futures is an
unbreakable Cassie sees barefooted
Ezekiel entering the train car there's a
guy who says New York is a whole another
level of crazy these days perhaps
referencing some recent superhero
activity in this universe he's holding a
PSP and Madame Webb is a Sony production
so it makes sense however the PSP was
discontinued in 2014 and it was released
in North America in March 2005 I would
say this guy could just have an old
Gaming device but this is Sony and any
opportunity they have to push the latest
version of anything onto US they're
going to use so I think this might be
specific now this gray-haired woman with
a newspaper does kind of looked like a
classic appearance of Madam web and you
know what I I don't know who this
actress is but I think she would have
been better cting than Dakota Johnson
there's a sign on this train card that
reads if you see something say something
which is often something you see in
public transportation especially after
9/11 but you can see Cassie reading this
as kind of a call to action she sees
something and has to act we also see a
poster of the Statue of Liberty in the
fetal position which is interesting so
Ezekiel attacks again hurting Anya and
Maddie and Julia and they all wearing
the same clothes that they were wearing
before the diner so maybe it's a dream
that Cassie has of those girls while
she's falling asleep on the train in her
mind putting all of them together in a
common Diner location that Peter Parker
would love to attend next section this
is an emergency get off the train that
man's trying to kill you why who are you
what is going
on I can see the
future oh what the hell now we see
Ezekiel Sim Spider-Man fighting some
cops on the 42nd Street subway station
and I got to say this guy loves choke
slamming women in particular like a
little too much it's like his one move
in this light we get a better look at
Ezekiel Spider-Man suit it is red
webbing on black red goggle eye pieces
and around his waist it kind of just
looks like red wiring that looks
separate from the rest of his suit the
music we hear throughout this trailer is
a remixed version of Billy ish's 2019
song bury a friend it's a dark edgy pop
song about being haunted the way Cassie
probably feels haunted by their own
future in the Woods by that crash taxi
where we saw Cassie standing before she
approached the diner at the top of the
trailer she explains to these other
girls that she can see the future and
Maddie tests it by throwing something at
her moving on I've seen that man before
so who is he Ezekiel Sims he was in the
Amazon with my mom when she was
researching spiders right before she
died so this next section explains
Cassie's history with Ezekiel Sims and
to go to Johnson is getting a little
dragg for her sleepy line reading on he
was in the Amazon with my mom when she
was researching spiders right before she
died honestly I wonder if this might
have been a line that was just recorded
in ADR for the trailer to give viewers
some Exposition the back of this photo
reads constance/ Ezekiel Peruvian Amazon
1973 so I just got to take a moment here
to note that morbius is stats came from
Costa Rica and from the Craven trailer
there seems to be some mystical
connection with Lion blood on an African
safari so if this movie is going with a
natural spider in the Peruvian Amazon it
could be that Sony is like trying to
create a villain verse based on Magic
and nature as opposed to like technology
and science on constant's Notebook you
can see a drawing of a spider and the
next page has some writing on it related
native toxic venomous ultimately I do
not think Ezekiel Sims is the villain of
this movie I just think that Cassie sees
him killing people in these Visions
Maybe plot to brainwash her future
Visions to turn her against Ezekiel and
this might be something happening to her
caused by the inheritors or Moran okay
next
clip wait I recognize you you live in my
building you're the paramedic yeah you
almost ran me
over you don't think this is weird how
we're all
connected it's honestly like the least
weird thing that's happened all day okay
we learned the three ways Cassy is
connected to these girls she lives in
his building she sees Julie at the
hospital and she nearly runs over Maddie
who skateboarded in front of her
ambulance so it really is just random
people connected to her in her life that
she forges the connection between they
did not start this movie as friends I
don't think we see Ezekiel jumping past
a Calvin Klein ad set photos also
revealed of some other ads that were
really from the early 2000s indicating
that this film does take place in an
earlier time period Cassie says it's the
least weird thing that has happened to
her all day making me wonder if a lot of
the events in this movie take place in
the same 24-hour period which would be
why the street close of Julia Ana and
MADD never change next part you have no
idea what those girls who come why
don't I think he can see into the
future he's trying to change what
happens Julia get
down okay we get a quick shot of Julia
in a pretty comic accurate black and
white Spiderwoman suit her hair is
hanging so she is upside down here then
Ana in her Arna suit we really only see
the eye pieces visible here but then
Maddie in a pretty great looking spw
woman suit with the mechanical arms
Cassie says that she thinks Ezekiel can
see into the future as well and we see
an older version of Ezekiel as Julia
casts a gold web like beam to cast
around Ezekiel his gray hair and the way
he clings to the side of the building
Barefoot is what Ezekiel Sims looks like
in his 2001 comic debut so I'm thinking
in her Visions Cassie might just see him
as a younger man and more of a threat
than he really is on to the next
part your future was almost so
different if you want to live you have
to trust me
get
ready
now and this is probably our best look
in Ezekiel Spider-Man suit as he stands
before the Calvin Klein ad and he's
holding something in his hand I want to
believe it's a Green Goblin pumpking
grenade but you know I assume it's going
to be something less interesting in a
Chase involving Ezekiel in the ambulance
we see a more controlled version of
cassy's glances into the future where
her eyes Zoom through this webbing and I
think this definitely is the web of life
and Destiny the P from the pepsicola
sign drops on Maddie and I assume her
mechanical arms are going to save her
but I am going to interpret this p as
the Peter Parker references in this
movie that keep dropping on these women
in summary what do I think is going on
in this Madame Web movie so Cassandra is
not a professional Clairvoyant like she
is in the comics she is a paramedic who
is just eager to save lives and one of
these near-death experiences awakens in
her the power to see a possible future
it is a more powerful version of what
the Spider-Man comics have called
arachno frequency AKA Spider Sense which
is a cosmic force that that links all
spider things together through the web
of life and Destiny this link is
something Cassie might have gotten from
her mother constant who with Ezekiel
Sims probably got bitten by some
supernaturally powered spider in the 70s
that genetically passed down to Cassie
this movie is going to use Ezekiel Sims
to establish that all Spider-Man and
Spider people were cosmically selected
by Fate to be a spider themed hero and
in this movie they're being hunted not
by Ezekiel Sims but Ezekiel Sims is
warning them about the real Hunters more
done or another inheritor who might be
Mike eps's character also unseen in this
trailer I just think this is Sony plans
to build out its liveaction corner of
the spiderverse to try to explain how
Tom Holland Peter Parker how Andrew
Garfield Peter Parker how Toby McGuire
Peter Parker are connected through a
Multiverse and I think Adam Scott is
going to be the Uncle Ben to a young
Peter in this universe and they'll use
that to explain how Madame Webb is
linked to the Peter Parker in any
Universe through the web of life and
Destiny she's going to see through the
Multiverse to peer at any superhero who
got bitten by a spider now does this
trailer make me excited for this I don't
know I kind of just want a Helen Mir and
cacan old lady Man web and a tech
Advanced chair teaming up with one of
these spider women and a Wily old
Ezekiel Sim scaring everybody it's just
Sony you don't have to make these
characters young sexy and cool recognize
that the characters are already sexy and
cool but old like I'm okay calling this
agism Stanley would never stand for this
but I want to know from you comment down
below with your thoughts on this trailer
does it make you excited for the movie
follow me on all social platforms at
eaos subscribe to all three channels of
the new rock stars Network support us by
grabbing something from our merch store
at nerd rot. shop thanks for watching
and I'll see you next time
bye
[Music]